[موسيقى]
في قلب ملبورن ، لمحة
عن منزل المستقبل ،
هذا هو الدفيئة مساحة معيشية مكتفية ذاتيًا ،
ومن بنات أفكار عدم وجود نفايات ،
نحن الداعمون الأوروبيون ، نحن الأنواع الوحيدة التي تولد
نفايات في الطبيعة ولا يوجد نفايات
إنه عملي للغاية ومنطقي للغاية ،
فلا يوجد شيء ذهب إلى هذا
المبنى لا يمكن إعادة تدويره أو
قابل للتحلل الحيوي
باستخدام الطاقة المتجددة.
نظام بيئي حيث يصبح كل شيء
مصدرًا
للغذاء لشيء آخر نقوم بتجميع
مياه الأمطار ونستخدمها
لأنظمة الاستزراع النباتي والسمكي ونزرع الطعام ،
ونستخدم المخلفات لصنع طعام للأسماك
، وقد تم تصميم جدار الفطر لتسخير
البخار من الحمام
الذي جربناه حوله  20
نوعًا مختلفًا
من الفطر الأسترالي الأصلي
الذي وجده صديق لي وهو يسير في الأدغال
وندفة الثلج هو ما أسماه
وهو لذيذ
من أماه  عندما كنت في الثانية عشرة من عمري ، بدأت في
الهوس حقًا بفكرة
المباني المنتجة ، حيث
إن إمكانات مبانينا لزراعة
الطعام وتنمية الطاقة
وأن تكون أكثر بكثير مما هي عليه
اليوم لا يمكنها التغلب على رائحة الطعام الطازج الذي
يتم حصاده
.  يُظهر أن لدينا
بعض الحلول المذهلة حيث
نعيش الدفيئة أيضًا
كمطعم والاستفادة من ما
يزرع في المبنى
هم الطهاة الوحيدون في المنزل جو
باريت
ومات ستون ليتمكنوا من النمو
وإنتاج الطعام في منزل صغير  البصمة في
وسط المدينة وتحويلها إلى
أطباق مثيرة
أمر فريد تمامًا وليس هناك ما
يشبه ذلك تمامًا ، نخرج إلى
الحديقة
حقًا ثم نختار من هناك ثم
نبدأ في الطهي ،
غالبًا ما يُسألون كيف يمكنك العيش بشكل أكثر
استدامة و  إنها إجابة بسيطة حقًا ،
إنها تأكل محليًا
وتناول الطعام بشكل موسمي
أكثر من ثلث انبعاثات
غازات الاحتباس الحراري تأتي من
الزراعة وفقًا لدراسة البكالوريا الصادرة عن الأمم المتحدة
توفر رؤية كاليفورنيا مخططًا
لمنزل أكثر خضرة
ونظامًا غذائيًا أكثر استدامة يتسبب
طعامنا في
إلحاق ضرر أكبر بالأرض أكثر من
أي شيء آخر ،
ولا نحتاج إلى الكثير من الأراضي لزراعة
الكثير من الغذاء مثل ما نفعله حتى نتمكن من إعادة
الأرض وإلى  يمكننا البدء في
زراعة المزيد من الأشجار في البرية ،
وهناك الكثير من الأضرار التي نحتاج إلى
إصلاحها
ولكن لا يمكننا القيام بذلك دون إيجاد
نظام بديل لإنتاج
الغذاء ، وأعتقد أن هذا هو
المكان الذي نعيش فيه.